well well well looks like ezra the killer
miller is back in the news but don't worry
it's not for attacking anyone he's learned to do
it in private now reject nation how's it going
thanks so much for clicking on this video if
you can leave a like that be i oh that's button
that's my new catchphrase moving forward yeah
yeah it's it's not going to stick so a couple
things to talk about that all revolve around how
reportedly wb is considering replacing ezra miller
as the flash and there's a very specific person
that they are potentially courting to fill in
the shoes for barry allen and i also want to
talk about why and uh don't get me wrong when
i say this i think he is perfect on the show
but about why i don't think this demand for
grant gustin to replace ezra miller is the best
move moving forward but first things first i saw
this trending on twitter the best place for all
news thank you elon musk it's being reported by
screen geek now i'm not too familiar with this
outlet that could be a crock of [__] for all i
know or they can have the most insane credibility
i'm not one to speak on it but it's being reported
by them that dylan o'brien is being courted to
replace ezra miller now i'm assuming it's not to
reshoot the flash movie but to take over you know
anything that involves the flash whether it be
solo films or crossover appearances after that
film finally comes out in 2045. now we've done
a couple of videos talking about the whole ezra
miller situation combined they're like 25 minutes
in total in-depth discussions one talking about
ezra's arrest the second one about as her second
arrest now personally i do think ezra miller
should be replaced i mean yeah for ezra's own
well-being as well so ezra can take some time off
especially if ezra seems intent on never speaking
to the public about it i mean he doesn't have to
just be you know nice to address some of this or
if wb can and for those who only focus on ezra's
mental health struggles you know saying like this
could be a robert downey junior situation have
a chance to prove themselves that's not like a
one-to-one comparison in order for ezra to make
a comeback edward ezra would need to you know go
away for a while to to come back and ezra clearly
needs to do some mental health healing which is a
long way to go and at this point it's just one too
many physical assaults against women so maybe we
should be more concerned about that and them it
probably doesn't help to keep ezra and these like
major blockbusters just my opinion we're talking
more about an up there but i'm just gonna leave it
at that for this video transition as far as dylan
o'brien goes i like this guy i think he's a cool
actor i feel like we were just talking about how
he was one of the casting rumors for nightwing
potentially i mean i thought it'd be a great pick
for nightwing too but the flag i could take him as
the new flasher now i haven't seen teen wolf
nor have i seen love in monsters i hear he is
fantastic in those movies but i do like his work a
lot in the maze runner i liked his work a lot in a
movie i didn't really like a lot american assassin
and i thought he played a really funny satirical
version of himself in the latest season of curb
your enthusiasm just that body of work alone
showed me that he could really do the action side
of being a superhero based off curb enthusiasm
he could definitely do comedy which i think is
necessary for playing barry allen because you know
i think to play barry allen you got to have like
some comedic chops but you know i don't i normally
associate dylan o'brien as a cool dude whereas
barry allen i think that you know unabashedly
geeky socially awkward nature to his character
is so essential to have when portraying this
person that's the end of the sentence maybe
that's some of those mannerisms and quirks and
and the other things i haven't seen but even if he
hasn't he's clearly a skilled enough actor where
i'm sure he could pull all that off really well
so if he ends up being the replacement i i don't
think it would be a bad choice at all i think
he has the right look for barry allen although
you know i can see you know that you know remember
like when andrew garfield was first cast as
spider-man there was that side of the you know
at least the internet that was like too sexy
for spider-man but he was perfect it's all
about the performance at the end of the day
while i do normally associate him as you know honk
a hong kong i don't imagine it would be the exact
same complaint and i think he's truly a talented
enough actor who can showcase a different side
that can embody barry allen i don't want this to
sound like i'm putting down you know the looks of
gustin and ezra miller you know he just has that
kind of uh that i wouldn't want to stand side by
side with dylan o'brien to you know protect
my own insecurities now that being said the
number one thing i am always hearing about when
it comes to recasting ezra miller for the flashes
why don't they get grant gustin to play
him you have a perfect flash right there
i agree he is perfect in that role absolutely
perfect now admittedly i have only seen up to
the first five seasons of the flashlight i
did fall off the show but i can't imagine
he's become you know a shitty actor in that
amount of time what we have in this version of
the you know the cinematic version of the flash
to really help distinguish this like assuming
that whoever the replacement is if there were
a continuation of this barry allen just with a
different actor in the role i don't really see the
point because we already seen grant gustin go on
pretty much a really long journey with the flash
i believe there's gonna be a ninth season of this
series which started off where barry allen did
not have powers and had powers and then has had
a whole lot of life experiences and growth over
the course of the past nine years or ten years for
that matter i think i'm not sure but it's been a
long time he's been playing the character whereas
this cinematic version of the flash even though
they are hopping too inspired by the flashpoint
story pretty early on the character of the
flash is still very much in his early years
the years that grant gustin's portrayal has
already done years ago he'd essentially just
be retreading territory that is already way past
with this character that's the character's already
much more mature and then you know just the back
of my point i did screenshot one thing because you
know it's like i gotta back this up something and
i i typed in on google as grant gustin leaving the
flash but so i found this according to deadline
grant gussen is finalizing a new contract to
return to the flash for season nine but it would
only be for one year rather than a multi-season
deal this new contract could see the actor netting
upwards of 200 000 dollars per episode i think he
deserves more money he's the freaking flash and
he's also reportedly capped his involvement at
15 episodes so well that's not it exactly you
know declaration of he is leaving the flash
after a while an actor does eventually
want to give up a role they can get tired
i feel like grant custom might want to move on to
other things while the flash movie obviously is
dealing with the multiverse inspired by flashpoint
something the show already kind of did and wasn't
the greatest and while i think grant gustin does
play a perfect barry allen i think ultimately it'd
be him doing like a remake of it all you know like
sure a different medium sure a different budget
different style not exactly the same stories
because there'd be like some different execution
to them absolutely but ultimately i think it might
just cause some confusion like they already had an
episode of christ on infinite earths where ezra
met grant they've already really made it crystal
clear that they are two separate berries so i
guess maybe if they wanted to convert the flash
show into the cinematic version of the flash
like continue the story of the show but in
in the movies by picking up where the series left
off although i then i think you might you know
segregate some audiences because they're racist
i'm gonna leave some audiences feeling a little
left out because i feel like a lot of people have
probably not seen all the seasons of the flash
i'm sure they could play some catch up for the
audience but ultimately could leave people feeling
like a little bit left out and feeling like maybe
they should have watched the show before watching
that you know what i mean i just feel like
it might create a little bit more problems
than necessary in my perspective it feels like it
might be better just to keep it you know clearly
distinguished and separate uh just for the
storytelling and audience association purposes
but if you guys have an idea for how it could work
that could reinvigorate grant gustin for the role
then let me know i'm open to ideas i'm an
open-minded guy i'm so open-minded you know i was
telling i'm telling my significant other we should
be in a polyamorous relationship you know like
i could be with other girls you could be with
other girls but you can't be with other guys
because that would make me very insecure i don't
want to deal with that level of jealousy in my
life you destroy me for some reason i thought this
would be the right video to poke at the cliche of
majority of the polyamorous relationships i
see in los angeles anyway guys what do you
think about this news leave your thoughts down
below you guys can subscribe and click that bell
i feel like it's kind of a weird video for
me and hey we will talk with you guys soon